vor allem so werden nach war ein paar
mehr videos machen ja ich erinnere mich
hat oder was geht hier ist euer granie
und heute gibt es ein ründchen team jump
league und team impliziert dass jemand
anders dabei ist und dieser jährige ist
kein geringer als mit deinen stimme los
zurück in den stimmbruch gewordenen
zurück und von dunkelheit die spitze
aber ich glaube das ist das erste
krankls video sei vor allem so werden
nach warum paar mehr videos machen ja
ich erinnere mich später hi
ja das ist das ungewöhnlichste video
freunde also ja ich habe so lange darauf
gewartet das ist was machte dann ach du
kommst es um die ecke als würdest du um
die ecke herum ejakulieren
wer diesen service gott auf jeden fall
ich habe mir hier einen harten
mitspieler homo organisiert weil felix
top das ja jeden tag und ich spiele
gerade das erste mal seit seit über
einer woche wieder ich war in italien im
urlaub und das jetzt wird es wieder zeit
für ein tutu duell der absoluter manga
fan und sowas na ja es geht skate es
geht wenn es über die straße laufen tut
das war heute das waren doch du und es
ihr habt doch so komplett übertrieben
und naturschutz oder endlos werden dass
auch übertrieben
da ich bin hacker danke nein also es und
lutz und links also ich hab dir so ein
bisschen die die sprache instituts davon
wenn ich auf mein leben klar kommt für
einen schub von staat und markt
wir wachsen für taxi und haben dann da
habe ich so die sprachnachrichten von
mir und just in folge spielt leben
klarkommen
hat er gedacht aber nicht mehr weil ich
kein alkohol keine milch im spiel ein
wenig genauer schlecht aber wir haben
das schon so gehört und dann haben wir
uns alle bewusst und dann haben die
sowas von übertrieben film nächsten tage
mit der ja also ich komme aus diesem
heraus ist wie so ein fluch manchmal
wollte ich da irgendwie so rein und dann
bemerke ich das gar nicht und dann rede
ich einfach so und dann irgendwann nicht
mehr und dann wieder merkst du das geht
schon wieder los
aber es ist keine kleine keine fixe
sprache kein slang sondern die piste
sprache ich hoffe du bist es liegt wenn
er sich ist wie ein albtraum vivaness
albträume da ich sah ein knab sein würde
ich werde meinem bruder ein albtraum
sein live stream wird wie scream ein
albtraum 0
also wirklich scharf aufnehmen ich bin
als meinen bin ich nur super pussy muss
ich auch zum anderen ort zum anderen
habe ich mir den auch vor kurzem erst
gegeben screen und ich bin eigentlich
ganz harmlos
also ich meine er wurde dann folge
hoffen aber es war ganz okay
ja bei mir war das immer so wenn ich
früher mit meiner ex-freundin filme
geschafft als ich erhofft hatte
dann hatte ich immer das ist eigentlich
voll behindert aber ich habe dann immer
so nicht hingehört und besonders bei den
schweinen doch wirklich aber die hose
gemacht
ehrlich ich bin absoluter fan feind von
von horrorfilmen
also ich hab ich also ich verstehe auch
nicht wie man sich so was irgendwie auf
partys oder so geben kann ja und nun
also ist das macht so fall die unzählige
stimmung also können wir auch ich sehe
auch echt den reiz einfach nicht dass
man sich in die hose zu köpfen
andere sehen das völlig anders vertritt
wirklich auch oder das kann man das ist
so eine sache eigentlich alles ja keiner
wissen
also leute wenn ihr das hier guckt nicht
behalten wird für euch aber hätten
kleine vorliebe dafür wird sich die hose
zu machen und es ist relativ kritisch
aber was soll zu tun wie behandelt er
das selbst erzählt er das öffentlich
beraten gerade ein bisschen aus münchen
oder david bösch okay er hat kein
problem mit wenn ich mich über den
lustig noch in videos macht ja in jedem
video möglich das ist ja schon fast so
einem konzept geworden
ich habe ein bisschen werbung ich hab ja
so ein konzept wo ich komme da wo
kommentieren
bestimmt einige und da habe ich ja da
kommt mir nur patrick kommentare nur
also in jedem kommentar ist mindestens
einmal patrick und mindestens einmal
hoch und sowieso ein running gag oder
mögen also ich hab kassel hat die leute
mal dazu animiert und seitdem ist total
ausgeartet und jeder schreibt nur noch
in die kommentare
wie viele patrick braucht man um eine
glühbirne auszuwechseln
ganz viele weil er es nicht alleine kann
[ __ ] sowas so richtig krachen
kommentare ich bald die ganze drunter
ich bin so ein oh ja du bist einfach 100
leute vor mir und genug
aber wenigstens ist er weniger platz 2
seht ihr denn war o2 jump dick gewesen
wären dann hätte ihr team kran bis
deutlich was sollen wir vorschlagen oder
profil nicht einfach ja warum denn nicht
ich bin so dumm ich hänge die ganze zeit
an diesem verpackten parcours den ich
schon mindestens 1000 mal gemacht habe
ich hasse das
jammert das bist du was bin ich es ich
habe ihm gesagt dass ich irgendwas bin
zu dunkel wird sagen ich hab das ab 1
gewonnen
du scheiß peter es tut mir leid
wir haben hinter dir
ich hab mir enchanted mit stein schwert
und das fast eisen da kam ein bisschen
schade auf mich drauf
was für ein schwerer stein schwert mit
sparsamen mitteln schalter wie wir
einfach durchmarschieren das ist ja
nichts führen lassen alle kaputt machen
ich habe hier zwei hinter mir aber ich
probiere die beide zuletzt nur schafft
die wende ein bruder
nein hab ich eine habe ich verdammt ja
richtig viele gerade ich hätte mir ein
bisschen rasieren sind das team herzen
was sind das eigentlich team herzen dass
wir haben oder
was ist los die karte schreiben kann
immer umschreiben kann ich oh mein gott
wir werden es gelingen ich bin normal
zufrieden dafür wie ich so pvp mäßig
unterwegs bin dafür dass ich über eine
woche nicht gespielt habe somit auch ein
pro und den spiel drin wo ich liebe dich
so sehr ich liebe dich aus dem aber ich
habe ich noch einiges vor mir bevor ich
bei waro zu voller form auflaufen können
ich kann ja leider diese mache ich
mitmachen weil ich nach europa machen
dreierteam wer hier bei mir wo bist du
mein gott wo bist du willst du das nein
ich habe noch ein herz
wir müssen jetzt richtig würde gerade
vom 30
und hier mit besserer hellen bitteschön
legst du versorgt mich so sehr wie man
eigentlich erzählt sich schlecker das
hören
ich musste
lasst uns zusammen kämpfen die machen
was die behinderten einfach die russen
oder ja komm lass den osten her läuft
sind wir aber ich habe deine ip ich mal
lud das hört was wollen wir ihm
ausrichten dass er besser ist genau weil
lutz weißt du was du weisst du was
aeroflex weißt du was er einfach machen
wollte er wollte dich einfach überreden
gegen mich in dörpen recht zu machen
diss tracks soll während du dich nicht
mehr störend auf den da wollte er
nämlich demnächst auf seine seite ziehen
gegen g8 und mich aber liegt weiß
natürlich wo er hingehört ich tue das
und das und stadtrand aktes ich habe wer
gewinnt die letzten beiden die die
überleben oder falten dann auch noch mal
wenn ich noch zwei leben habe bevor wir
die gekillt haben dann töte mich einfach
deine stifter oder foto wir machen dann
1 gegen den 1 1 gegen den 1
gegen den orden wir lassen das du und
wie das konto kommt ist hinter mir her
ich habe getrackt von den andern
integrieren
wenn man die runde kommt oder vorne sind
sie als ob die sichter verkämpfen
training richtig feines ohne sich da zu
verkämpfen auch noch zu zweit in dieses
getränk mit dem feige drin
oder es gab ich anlagen dankeschön
wollte lasten
das gibt mir denn wer sitzt wo gott ist
da noch ein leckerer aber ich krieg den
oracle gut gemachte den schuh ich habe
keine ahnung gibt er jedoch nicht ich
einmal töten
was du für hits einstecken kannst du ich
werde dich so zerstören macht aber jetzt
habe ich aber nicht mehr auf dem track
mich wahrscheinlich auch nicht
eigentlich müssen uns gegen gleich auf
dem trecker haben also ich hab dich von
rupprecht aber davon bist du schwul aber
nicht direkt sondern machen irgendwie
alles auszugleichen
mit dem weg die mutter der kleinen weg
du kleiner schlawiner
ich bin kein kleiner stern großen bogen
der tut was natürlich wird man durch
mich unterschätzt nach der fast
überhaupt nicht mit dem strom geschaffen
als westen ein lichtbogen schiesser okay
das gewinnst du das motiv jetzt musst du
jetzt auch noch sagen mit dem herzen wir
haben es aber gleich viele hits gegeben
aber die runde war definitiv sehr cool
wenn ihr sehen wollt wie patrick
beleidigt wird dann checke definitiv mal
den link ganz oben der beschreibung aus
da ist nämlich der kanal vom lieben
felix und da würde ich sagen was das mit
dem lang ersehnten video seit war o2 und
sie sind zwar nicht mal wieder macht's
gut